les ennemis de mes ennemis sont mes amis
voilà ce qui décrit l'esprit de la lutte
biologique en agriculture depuis
quelques années on parle de plus en plus
de cette approche en lutte biologique au
lieu de miser sur des pesticides on fait
appel notamment à des insectes
prédateurs pour contrôler les insectes
nuisibles ceux qui font des ravages aux
champs et l'usage de drones pour
disséminer les insectes amies pourraient
bien faire de nouveaux convertis
[Musique]
ici la ferme on a 1850 à
cultive surtout maïs grain soya blé
consommation humaine ainsi que du sexe
mais ce matin on est testé des
alternatives au pesticides pour
combattre le VGO h le verre gris
occidental du haricot c'est une
problématique qu'on a dans la région ici
depuis
5-6 ans la manière traditionnelle c'est
d'utiliser l'insecticide et ça vous
aimez pas ça non parce que en fait on
veut sauver les coccinelles qui sont nos
alliés pour combattre le puceron il y a
d'autres insectes qui sont pas nuisibles
dont les abeilles les guêpes les
pollinisateurs
bougiendront a récemment fait
connaissance avec le vert gris
occidental du haricot un insecte qui
contrairement à ce que son nom indique
s'attaque au maïs dès l'ami juillet
l'agriculteur cherche à localiser
l'ennemi dans ses champs de Saint-Anicet
on commence le suivi présentement on est
à l'étape départ j'ai installé mon piège
le 2 jours on va voir si la récolte
[Rires]
là on est dans mon champ de maïs qui est
normalement le pire pour le VGA
c'est un papillon de nuit qui vient
pondre des œufs c'est l'arbre s'attaque
au maïs c'est plus à cause des gros
dégâts jusqu'à presque personne
dans les grains
suite le VGO h avant on savait qu'ils
migré des États-Unis jusque chez nous
mais aujourd'hui on sait qu'il est
implanté au Québec il est capable de
survivre au Québec donc il y a des
populations qui vont pouvoir augmenter
éventuellement si on contrôle pas cet
insecte là
aujourd'hui le chercheur expérimente une
nouvelle méthode pour neutraliser
l'insecte nuisible
et on démarre
[Musique]
nous avec les drones ça c'est une
méthode qui est quand même beaucoup plus
rapide on a pas besoin non plus de
marcher dans le champ on n'a pas besoin
d'utiliser machinerie donc on peut
survoler les parcelles de maïs c'est une
méthode qui est quand même assez rapide
les seul distribuer en drone contiennent
des milliers de minuscules guêpes qu'on
appelle des trichogrammes elles pondent
directement à l'intérieur des œufs de
l'insecte visé les larves du vert gris
occidental du haricot ne se
développeront pas et la majorité des
épis de maïs éviteront les dommages
c'est dans cette ferme de Saint-Jacques
le mineur en montée régie que l'idée par
mission a été développée on élève des
insectes prédateurs qui neutralisent les
insectes ravageurs une méthode de lutte
biologique popularisée en Amérique du
Nord par Sylvia Todorova toute ma vie je
travaille dans le lutte biologique
contre les insectes ravageurs même dans
mon pays d'origine le Bulgarie je
faisais ça dans l'Académie de sciences
bulgare quand je suis arrivée ici
personne m'a pris au sérieux elle va
faire des bébés tissus
ça existait même pas vraiment surtout
pour l'utilisation d'un champ maintenant
c'est différent et plus en plus du monde
utilise vraiment des insectes des
produits microbiologiques des solutions
biologique on va aller dans une roulotte
où on produit des insectes prédateurs
les crises
on essaie garder nos élevages isolés
pour éviter contamination mais là on
fait les prédateurs ici on produit 10
espèces ils sont très spécifiques
certains s'attaquent contre le pyrale du
maïs dans certains contrats dans les
pommes il n'y a pas vraiment danger
parce que nos espèces sont très
spécifiques il s'attaque vraiment contre
une certaine espèce donnée
[Musique]
les trichogrammes produits par anatis
bioprotection sont souvent asséchés dans
de petites cartes blanches qu'on appelle
des tricots cartes
dans cette entreprise maraîchère de
Saint-Rémy en montée régie les tricots
cartes sont très appréciés lorsque vient
le temps de lutter contre la pyrale du
maïs un autre insecte qui peut faire des
ravages dans les champs
ça déclenche complètement le légume
qu'on va récolter parce que la pyrale du
maïs a la pique au centre de l’épi puis
ça déplace complètement le Miss qu'on
peut avoir quasiment 50% de pertes si on
laisse ça aller là
pour le moment c'est la sixième
application qu'on fait dans ce champ là
puis on n'a pas eu besoin de mettre
aucun insecticide on prend la feuille on
la met dans le trou et on l'insère
jusqu'au fond pour être sûr que quand il
vende la carte ne tombera pas ici il y a
de 4000 à 5000 œufs là-dedans il y en a
la moitié c'est des morts et la moitié
des femelles
[Musique]
et si sur la en montée rigide la
population de pirates du maïs est
intense
[Musique]
mais distribuer des tricots cartes à la
main ça prend du temps les travailleurs
de l'entreprise maraîchère doivent
parcourir 172 acres de champs à pied une
opération qui prend plusieurs jours et
doit être répété de 6 à 8 fois pendant
l'été
[Musique]
vous avez essayé une année la
technologie par drone d'application de
trichogramme par drone tu as quoi votre
pourcentage de réussite moi d'après moi
le pourcentage de réussite était de 80 à
90% à cause que la capsule et je
laissais tomber au sol puis ici il y a
une pluie les gouttelettes de pied fait
tomber de la boue sur la capsule ça
bosse les ports les insectes sont
prisonniers quand ils vendent bien
binfort on peut pas appliquer ces avec
les drones tandis que les trichogrammes
qui mouille qui fasse beau on peut les
appliquer comme on veut entre moi je
suis vendu au cap de d'être
[Musique]
donc ce sont les capsules de tritogramme
pour cet étang ici l'avantage qu'on
pourrait avoir avec le dépôt par drone
c'est de lutter un peu contre le manque
de main d'oeuvre
cette représentante d'un géant de
l'agroalimentaire supervise aujourd'hui
une expérience chez un de ses
fournisseurs la plus grosse ferme
biologique du Québec située à
saint-pauly carpe les champs de la
compagnie s'étendent de la Montérégie
Ouest à l'Ontario un territoire
difficile à couvrir avec des tricots
cartes déposés à la main
on sait quelles opérations étaient
menées dans nos champs puis on va
pouvoir comparer un champ dans lequel on
a déposé des tricots grammes par drone
versus un champ dans lequel on a déposé
des tricots cartes un manuellement là on
va pouvoir vérifier avec nos débustage
si on a une différence au niveau de
l'efficacité est-ce que quand la capsule
tombe on le trouve et bien en l'air
est-ce que au contraire le trou dans
lequel les guêpes peuvent sortir est-ce
que il y a les retourner ça c'est des
choses qu'on va regarder auquel on va
prêter attention
quel avenir sera réservé à l'utilisation
de cette technologie
ça dépendra des résultats des
expériences menées en chant
chose certaine drone ou pas les bio
pesticides ont levant dans les voiles
même chez les producteurs conventionnels
de maïs
nous notre but c'est pas être biologique
le bus c'est d'être éco-responsable
d'utiliser le moins possible de
pesticides si on n'a pas le choix on va
en mettre mais si on a le choix
d'appliquer les tricoteurs en mettant
des triangles mais on va le faire
on fait notre part pour l'environnement
personne n'aime utiliser des pesticides
donc on essaie de trouver des solutions
un peu plus éco-responsables les
agriculteurs ils pensent pour leur santé
aussi c'est le premier qui sont exposés
et toutes les preuves qui ont une voix
maintenant pour certaines insecticides
qui sont cancérogènes les autres qui
font Parkinson les producteurs ils
voient tout seul je suis pas contre les
insecticides chimiques mais au moins à
diminuer ceux qui sont les plus toxiques
et éliminer ceux qui sont très toxiques
[Musique]